veterinarian's from the forepaws
international animal charity and their
palestinian colleagues are ensuring the
animals are fit to travel media interest
is high it's not every day an entire zoo
in the Gaza Strip is evacuated for
deuterium cell phone drawing on recent
developments we think these animals just
simply don't have a future here
when the zoo started in 2007 there were
120 animals now there are only 15 left
in just a few hours the remaining
animals at this private Zoo will be
leaving among them monkeys Turtles a
pelican and EMU and the targa they'll
travel out of the sealed off gaza strip
across the border to israel some will
then travel on to south africa others to
jordan after work with more than four
countries for government for authorities
and this is a big challenge here the
animals faced food shortages and were
poorly cared for part of the zoo was
destroyed in the 2014 war many of the
animals perished
the zoo's owner put their mummified
remains on display but the problem
remains the lack of visitors money and
experience zookeepers family members are
glad the animal charity is now helping
despite the fact the animals are going
we're happy they're now in safe hands to
feed them to water them to take care of
them lasses the tiger grew up in this
tiny cage after being smuggled into Gaza
from Egypt through a tunnel
now his destination is South Africa this
Vega and your touches across here do
just a bit on so it's ready I think for
I think with my experience so Tiger
would be very great and thankful the
last of the animals are being put into
their transporters they'll have to pass
through both the Hamas and Israeli
checkpoints before they can hit the road
and before the zoo can finally close
you